the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok getting getting started I thought I'd
add a few words about a question that
came up after class suppose in that
discussion last time where you were
given three you were given a distance
matrix you were given the distance
between x1 and x2 between x2 and x3 and
between x1 and x3 and you wanted to find
points that satisfied that well we're
going to fail on this example because if
the distance here is 1 the distance here
is 1 then by the triangle inequality the
distance from x1 to x3 could not be more
than 2 and when we square it it could
not be more than 4 and here it's 6 so
what's going to happen what goes wrong
in that case yeah I hadn't commented on
that and I'm not sure that that the
paper that I referenced does so so I had
to do a little search back in the
literature cuz people couldn't overlook
this problem so this is the triangle
inequality fails so that and it's not
going to help to go into ten dimensions
because the triangle inequality doesn't
doesn't change and it's still there in
ten dimensions and we're still failing
it so what happens well what could
happen
do you remember and you'll have to
remind me the the key equation you
remember we had an equation connecting
connecting so what is the matrix D for
this problem so D is this is a three by
three matrix with these distances
squared and it was convenient to use
distances squared because that's what
comes into the next steps so of course
the distance from each X to itself is 0
the distance from x distance squared was
that this one was that but this one is 6
ok so that's the distance matrix and we
would like to find the job was to find
week and I'm just going to write down we
cannot find x1 x2 and x3 too to match
those distances so what goes wrong well
there's only one thing that could go
wrong when you connect this distance
matrix D to the matrix X transpose X you
remember the position matrix maybe I
called it G this this is giving so G IJ
is the dot product of X I with XJ oops
make that into a J here thank you so g
IJ is the matrix of dot products and the
great thing was that we can discover
what that matrix that matrix G comes
directly from D comes directly from D
and of course what do we know about this
matrix of cross products we know that it
is positive semi-definite
so what goes wrong well just in a word
when we write out that equation and
discover what G is if the triangle
inequality fails we learn that G is G
doesn't come out positive definite
that's really all I want to say and I
could push through the example G will
not come out positive definite if D if
that's D because it can't if it came out
positive definite then we could find an
X so if we had the G then the final step
you remember is to find an X well we
know that if G is positive semi-definite
there are multiple ways to find an x you
know this is positive semi definite
matrices is what you get out of X
transpose X s and we can find an x given
a G we can find G given an X so it has
to be that this won't be true that the
matrix G that comes out of that equation
will turn out not to be positive
definite so it's it's really quite nice
it's a beautiful little bit of
mathematics that if if and only if the
triangle inequality is satisfied by
these numbers if and only if then the
matrix that in the in the D matrix then
the G matrix that comes out of this
equation which I haven't written is
positive semi-definite if the triangle
inequality is okay we can find the
points if the triangle inequality is
violated like here we then the matrix G
is not positive semi-definite has
negative eigenvalues and we cannot find
the point yeah I could recall the G
matrix
the the G equation but it's coming to
you in the two page section that does
just distance matrices okay that that's
just I sort of like made a point it's
nice to have specific numbers and I
could get the specific numbers for G and
we would see no way it's not positive
definite okay so that's just tidying up
last time I have another small problem
to talk about and then a big question of
whether deep learning actually works I
had an email from an expert last night
which changed my view of the world about
that question as you can imagine the the
change in my world was I had thought the
answer was yes and I now think the
answer isn't no so that's like rather a
big issue for eighteen oh six five but
we'll let's see about that later okay
okay now I'll proquest these problem so
prou Krusty's and i it's included in the
notes it's that name comes from a Greek
myth are you guys into Greek myths so
what was the story of per Krusty's he
was at Procrustes who adjusted the
lengths of his so he had a special bed
for crusties bed certain lengths and
then he had visitors coming and instead
of adjusting the length of the bed to
fit the visitor for Krusty's adjusted
the length of the visitor to fit the bed
so either stretch the visitor or chopped
off
part of the visitor so anyway it's it's
the Greeks like this or a thing okay so
anyway that's that's a Greek myth for
eighteen oh six five okay so the whole
idea there percuss teas problem is to
make something fit something else so the
so the two things are so suppose I'm
just in three dimensions I have two
vectors here sort of a basis for a
two-dimensional space and over here I
have people space scientists might have
one computation of the of the positions
of satellites then of course they
wouldn't be off by as much as this
figure shows but then they have another
computation using different coordinates
so it so it's it's partly rotated from
this picture but also it's partly got
roundoff errors and an error in it
between the two so the question is
what's the best best orthogonal
transformation so this is this is a
bunch of vectors X 1 X 2 2 X n let's say
and I want to multiply them by an
orthogonal matrix no maybe I'd do it on
the other side I think I do yeah q to be
as close as possible to this other set Y
1 y 2 up to Y n so let me just say it
again
I have two sets of vectors and I'm
looking and they're different like those
two sets and I'm looking for the
orthogonal matrix that as well as
possible takes this set into this one of
course if this was if this was an
orthogonal basis and this was an
orthogonal basis
then we would be home free q we could
get equality we could take an orthogonal
basis directly into an orthogonal basis
with a orthogonal matrix Q in other
words if X was an orthogonal matrix and
Y was an orthogonal matrix we would get
it the exact correct q but that's not
the case so we're looking for the best
possible so that's the the problem then
minimize if I minimize over orthogonal
matrix matrices Q and I just want to get
my notation to be consistent here okay
okay so I've I see that I starting with
the Y's and mapping them to X's so let
me ask the question what are thuggin 'el
matrix q multiplies the Y's to come as
close as possible to the x's so so I
over all orthogonal Q's I want to
minimize Y Q minus X in the Frobenius
norm squared so Frobenius we're into the
Frobenius norm remember the of a matrix
this is a very convenient Normand in
data science to measure the size of a
matrix and we have several possible
formulas for it so the so let me call
the matrix a and the Frobenius norm
squared
okay so what's one expression in terms
of the entries of the matrix the numbers
a IJ and the matrix the Frobenius norm
is just treats it like a long vector so
it's a 1 1 squared plus a 1 2 squared
all the way
the first plus second row just I'll say
n n square ok sum of all the squares
just treating it like a long vector okay
this but that's a awkward expression to
write down
so what other ways do we have to find
the Frobenius norm of a matrix let's see
I can look at this as a transpose a is
that right a transpose a so what what's
happening there
remind me what yeah I I would get all
that I would get all these by taking the
matrix a transpose times a but what
sorry I'm not I'm not I haven't I've
lost my threat of of talk here
so here's oh and then I take the trace
of course so that first row first column
of a times that one will give me the one
set of squares and then that one times
the other one the next one will give me
the next set of squares right so this is
going to if I look at the trace so now
let me I so I'm just want to look at the
diagonal here so it's it's the trace you
remember the trace of a matrix of a
matrix M is some down the guy M 1 1 M 2
2 down to mmm
it's it's some it's a diagonal Sun and a
everybody with me here is now the so
that term on the diagonal of a transpose
a gives me all of that then or maybe
I've maybe I should be doing a a
transpose and the point is it doesn't
matter so or the trace of a a transpose
that would be those would both give give
the correct Frobenius norm squared so
traces are going to come into this
little problem
now there's another formula for the
Frobenius norm even shorter well
certainly shorter than this one
involving a sum of squares and what's
that one what's the other way to get
this same answer if I look at the SVD
look at singular values I think that
this is also equal to Sigma what are
some square of all the singular values
so it's three nice expressions for the
Frobenius norm the nice ones involve a
transpose a or a a transpose and of
course that connects to the singular
values because what are what's the
connection between singular values and
those and these guys a transpose a or a
a transpose the the singular values are
the or the singular value squared are
the eigenvalues of a transpose a and
then when I add up the trace I'm adding
up the eigen values and that's the that
gives me the Frobenius norm squared so
this is a that's a that tells us
something important
which we can see in different ways that
so we to solve this problem we're gonna
need various facts like the QA in the
Frobenius norm is the same as a in the
Frobenius no why why is that why so here
I'm multiplying every column by the
matrix Q what happens to the length of
the column when I multiply it by Q
doesn't change so I could add up the
lengths of the columns all squared here
I wrote it in in terms of rows but I
could have reordered that and got it in
terms of columns that's because the
length of Q times any any vector square
it is the same as the vector square and
these take these to be the columns of a
so for column by column the
multiplication by Q doesn't change the
length and then when I add up all the
columns squared I get the Frobenius norm
squared and another way to say it let's
make the connection between the this
fact that Q didn't change the Frobenius
norm and this fact that therefore b
Gnaeus norm is expressed in terms of
their Sigma's so whoa so what does Q due
to the Sigma's I want to see in another
another way the answer to why so if I
have a matrix a with singular values I
multiply by Q what happens to the
singular values don't change don't
change that's the key point about saying
to their values if I multiply so a has
an SVD u Sigma V transpose and Q a
we'll have the SVD qu Sigma V transpose
so all I've changed when I multiply by Q
all I changed was the first factor the
first orthogonal factor in the SVD I
didn't change the Sigma's they're still
sitting there so and of course I could
do also Q on the other side different Q
same Q or a different Q on the other
side would show up here and would not
change the Sigma's and therefore would
not change the Frobenius norm so that's
these are important properties of this
4b Gnaeus norm it's a it looks messy
right down in that form but it's much
nicer in these forms and in that form
okay okay so now if I can just then then
we saw that it involves traces so let me
make a few observations about traces
okay so I'll just we want to we want to
be able to play with traces and that's
something we really haven't done here's
a fact that the trace of a transpose B
is equal to the trace of B transpose a
of course if B is a it's clear and all
and it's equal to the trace of B a
transpose so you can do little changes
in your in your matrix without changing
the trace let's see why one of these is
true why why is that first statement
true
how is that matrix related to this
matrix it's just a transpose if I take
the transpose of that matrix I get that
so what happens to the trace I'm adding
down the diagonal the transpose has no
effect
clearly this is just the fact that the
trace doesn't change has not changed
when you transpose a matrix because the
diagonal has not changed now what about
this guy I guess we're getting back to
old-fashioned 1806 five remembering
facts about linear algebra because this
is pure linear algebra so what's this
one about
this says that I can reverse the order
of two matrices I'm now looking at the
connection between those two and and and
so so let me just to use different
letters C D equals the trace of DC I can
flip the order that's that's all I've
done here is I've reversed B with a
transpose i reversed C with D okay so
why is that true why is that true well
how shall we see the truth of that fact
so these are really convenient facts
that make a lot of people use the trace
more often than we have in 1806 five I'm
not a big user of arguments based on
trace but these are identities that that
go a long way with with many problems so
let's see why that's true any time you
think about trace you've got two
languages to use you can use the
eigenvalues it's the sum of the
eigenvalues or you can use the diagonal
entries because it's the sum of the
diagonal entries let's use eigenvalues
how are the eigenvalues of CD related to
the eigenvalues of DC they're the same
if these matrices are raked
then there might be some extra zero like
in guys because they have would have
different shapes but zeros are not going
to affect the trace so so this is the
same same nonzero eigenvalues okay and
so on yeah okay let me just let me let
me try to tell you the steps now to get
the correct Q in or let me tell you the
answer first and I'm realizing that the
all-important question for does deep
learning actually work we're going to
run out of time today because we only
have a few minutes left
I suggest we bring that question back up
because like it's pretty important to a
lot of people there's a you know I had
lunch with Professor Adelman and he said
you know deep learning and neural nets
have had like a record amount of
publicity
and hype for for a sort of computational
algorithm and but I had I've had people
now tell me that typical first if you
create a network using Alex's designed
for example the chances are that it
won't be successful that the successful
networks have been been worked on and
experimented with and a good structure
has emerged but didn't wasn't there at
the start so I think that's a topic for
for a Monday and I'm really just
realizing from talking to people in the
field that
it's by no means automatic that that
structure even if you put in a whole
bunch of layers it may not be what you
want okay so I'm let me finish this
argument today let me give you the
answer so what's the good cue
I have matrices Y and X and the idea is
that I take its I look at Y transpose X
so that'll be all the dot products of
one set of vectors were the other set of
vectors that's a matrix and I do its SVD
u Sigma V transpose so so multiply this
x trans a two bases that you're given of
course if Y was the same as X if it was
an orthogonal basis you'd have the
identity no questions but generally we
have it has an SVD and we're looking for
the for a orthogonal matrix of the best
q is doesn't it I mean it's the right
time for four expressions of amazement
it is UV transpose okay so that so
that's gives us the answer we're given x
and y we're looking for the best q and
the answer comes in the simplest
possible way compute Y transpose X
compute its SVD and use the orthogonal
matrices from the SVD yeah and I'm out
of time so so proof it's it's three line
later either either to just send you the
section online or to discuss it in class
Monday but I
I'm really planning Monday to start with
question four and being well to ask a
whole lot of people everybody I can find
about that important question is does
deep learning usually work how what can
you do to make sure it works or give
yourself a better chance to have it work
so let's that's that's up for Monday
then good